right all right
okay so we all welcome to
um this middle of the september meetup
um it's really nice to have us here
um so it's a joint meet up um as well
might be aware it's some pi data hamburg
and
the
nlp
um hamburg nlp so just to
um
see before we get started we should know
that this
section is recorded so if you don't feel
comfortable with maybe your face being
shown or
your name or whatever you could just
mute your mic and turn off your
tone of your camera and also maybe
um change your name preferably as as
just to let us know that it's recorded
um so
first of all um if you have questions
you should just raise your hands first
so you have any question you just use
your hand you can use the icon here so
this raised feature in zoom
and then one of the modulators would on
with you subsequently i would introduce
the other modulators to us and also the
organizing committee
um so
just to walk through the agenda so
basically having um
so we started eating thirty six thirty
p.m or some
german time yeah so um we'll have our
first talk um philip schmidt and have a
break then we have a second talk by
leticia and then
subsequently
we're open to um discussions and
networking
so
yeah so just to
um state briefly so for pi data we have
a pi data global
um conference that's coming up october
28 to 30th and i'm excited for it i
don't know about you i'm really excited
and
yeah so basically it's um
a conference that's going to take this
online however we have the scholarship
that is an impact scholarship that's for
um underrepresented groups
um so it's um open open to people that
are looking to develop their career as
well so i'm going to put
details in the chat subsequently you see
the details in the chat for us to
um
register if you're interested for the
scholarship so the conference is online
like i said and
uh more details i will share in the in
the chat
so
yeah
so just to introduce pi data ambulators
so we have pi data amber pi data is a
global community for developers and
users of open source data tools for data
analyses and machine learning and so so
forth
and um we also in collaboration with um
non-focus so private is an educational
program of non-focus as well where
non-focus is a non-profit organization
in the u.s
so just to have more details about us
you could um check
our twitter so that's our twitter pi
data amber linkedin and um
also non-focus we have um our
youtube channel as well pi data tv so
subsequently um we release videos of um
this particular
meetup of meet up subsequent meetups on
the on the um youtube channel so we
could
go there and check and
watch and review and yeah sometimes i i
also go back sometimes to
watch some certain things some
clarifications to get some clarification
some questions that we asked just to get
answers to them
yes so um
so now this is the pi data amber
team so um so the first person maria i
don't know if maria is there maybe she
could say hello or maybe
maria
then myself obina
then alexandros
alexandros then daphne daphne as well
then kai tea
and camilla
so
this
we're part of the pi data hamburg
organizing committee
and um
so also
for the pi data amber we're calling for
participation speakers we're interested
in having speakers so if
you're building something interesting
with open source data tools and you want
to speak about it
we're actually looking forward to
welcoming you um
to speak about whatever you're working
on you're interested
so you could reach out to any of the um
organizing committee members
and also you're looking out for
volunteers
so
metal planning speaker outreach and
support
yeah we have hands on deck but then
having more people is not a bad idea i
think so if you're interested and you
want to so this is actually my first
time of organizing something like this
and if you want to have the opportunity
to do that it's it's a very good um
place to start so we're looking out for
volunteers as well
so i'll hand over to a representative
from the
nlp hamburg nlp to continue from there
thank you
hi i'm bastian
i'm an organizer from the group meet nlp
and
we are a community um
that tries to build the platform all
about natural language processing
and um
we are based in hamburg but uh
from the start uh we were forced from
corona to
um
yeah uh have our
meetups um
online and we really appreciated that we
were able to have um speakers and um
yeah
participations from all over the world
and we really liked that and so
also
when the corona situation will change we
will definitely um
keep this this way and uh we'll
try to stream our meetups also um
online so that everyone can join um at
the moment uh
our meetups are roughly every two months
and um
yeah uh like i said we're trying to
build a community so we
would like to have not just the meetups
but also
um provide some links to libraries um
share some code and um
at the moment uh we mainly do that can
you um
go on one slide further
okay
interesting it's
um
thank you um
yeah we are
mostly uh
currently based at the community snack
channel
our website is still in progress
and
we are also
right now
looking for new members in the
organization team
and
we would
yeah really like if also
people from different different ethic
groups or
different um
genders would like to participate there
because at the moment we are only for
white males and um
we really think this is yeah
not showing the diversity that we
would like to um to have to have in our
group and so
um maybe
of course also if you are a white male
and you really like to join uh
you are welcome of course but um
yeah everyone else please uh
please um
yeah like to we really like uh
other people also
okay
thanks camilla
um so
if you're interested just contact us and
um
yeah um lucas
will also present us a small surveys
that we
did lucas
hi sorry i think my internet connection
is very unstable so i try to do it
without video so i'm very happy to to be
here today and
yeah we need your help because
we would like to create a european
landscape for nlp focused companies so
we heard a lot of very impressive
speakers during the last year
on nlp focused topics and we would like
to create a european landscape on nlp
focused companies and to maintain a
calendar of nlp events and for this we
need your input so um please fill in
the form and send us the nlp companies
and nlp events you know so we will then
share it and combine it into a european
landscape so i currently are i just send
um or filled in a link
to the form so please help us out help
us to
enrich this european nlp landscape
okay
and just to be clear it's natural
language processing it's not new
linguistic
programming
we had that before
so natural language processing that's
the stuff we like and know about
okay um just to
say um
theos for the evening so myself obina
and bastian bastiana stopped as well
then lucas because we just stopped and
alexandria's
now i'll the
andover to alexandros
um to
continue from here
uh philip speaks first so
okay you
oh okay okay okay okay so yeah
sorry about that
okay so
without further ado i think
i can speak for the meat nlp amber
community in uh saying that first of all
we're very happy to be part of this
event and second of all we're also just
as happy to introduce philip schmidt our
first speaker of the evening he's an ml
engineer and tech lead at a name that is
ubiquitous i think in nlp research
hugging face and he'll give us an
introduction
to the new sagemaker integration hugging
face
hi everyone um
i think you need to stop sharing your
screen and then i can
take over
so
you should be able to
see my presentation right
yes
and only the presentation
okay perfect and yeah thanks again for
the invitation i'm happy to talk to you
today and i will not only give an
introduction into the new sagemaker
introduction integration i will also
talk about the hacking phase ecosystem
which like dramatically grew over the
last couple of months but before we get
started so to me i'm philip i'm from
germany in nuremberg i'm a machine
learning engineer and tech lead at
hugging face and if you have any
questions ideas feel free to reach out
to me on twitter linkedin
via email or we have like a big forum at
hugging face on the discuss the
tigerface.co
so open the thread and tag me there
happy to help you answer questions or
like just chat with you
and for the agenda today and first i
will talk about taking phase as a
company how we work and how we live
then the second part will be about the
hanging face ecosystem how we basically
created like an open source open science
system used by
probably anyone at nlp right now and
then at the end we will do a short
little hands-on session how you can use
the new sagemaker integration
but before we begin i start with a
little guessing game which is probably
obvious to the most of you the question
here is um what is the common link
between the tesla autopilot the google
mail auto completion the facebook
translation service
feature and the bing search results
i guess the answer might be quite
obvious it's like of course the
transformer model and 3d transformer
model tesla is able
to
yeah understand the vector space with
their cameras gmail is able to predict
how you want to finish your sentence
facebook is able to automatically
translate your post into over 150
different languages
and asking being a question in natural
language and it understands and
retrieves the information relevant for
your search but another piece between
the for transformers use case we see
which is less common is that each of
those handle like billions of prediction
each day and if you are not google
facebook microsoft or tesla these are
like rare cases where companies are able
to train and deploy transformer models
and that's why our mission at hugging
phase is to democratize nlp and
transformers or rather now saying it was
to democratize nlp and we now want to
basically tran
democratize machine learning in general
because hugging pha
transformers are literally eating the
world of machine learning we introduced
this year several
architectures for speech and visions and
the traction of it is like amazing we
have already over 400 different speech
models and over 100 different vision
models for image classification
automatic speech recognition so
transformers are not only limited to nlp
now and that's why we want to give
everyone in the world excess of machine
learning to it
and you are probably asking yourself
okay how can a small startup of 50 to 70
people achieve something what google and
microsoft are doing basically every day
and the answer is pretty easy one part
of it is our awesome
growing community the transformers
library for example has currently close
to 1 000 individual active contributors
and on the right side you can see the
github stars growing over time within
red the transformers library next to
other amazing open source projects like
mongodb or spark and you can see
basically transformers is skyrocketing
since the release of it
and in addition to it we have a
yeah a
public model hub basically with over 15
000 available community created models
in over 200 different languages
the second part of
yeah how we can achieve this is our open
source ecosystem we have created several
open source projects which increase and
makes it easy for companies and
individuals to use transformer based
models but we are going to d we are more
into depth about all of them laters and
another part i definitely want to
highlight is we have created a new curse
earlier this year we launched the first
part of it the second part will come at
the end of november this course will
teach you anything you need to know
about nlp and transformers using all our
open source libraries from transformers
data sets tokenizer and accelerate and
the best part about the course it's
basically free so you can go to
hackingface.com
course and immediately start and every
like execution and training will be used
using a google call app
and another awesome part about this is
that the course comes in like two
variants so if you are a pie touch user
you can do the course in pytorch and if
you are a tensorflow user you can use
tensorflow to go through the code uh the
course
and so far we talked about the open
source and the community but there are
over 5000 different companies using
transformers already in production and
here you can see a few examples of how
companies are using transformers today
for example we have monso
which uses text classification to
accelerate a custom support or check
which uses transformers to extract and
retrieve information we already
mentioned being earlier on the first
slide to understand your search queries
and
like your answers your question and
these other use cases but
how are you able to implement or bring
this into your company and projects
and that's pretty easy that's where the
hiking phase ecosystem comes in and as i
already said the hacking phase ecosystem
crew dramatically over the last couple
of months and it's like almost hard to
fit basically any service and library
into one slide so either we need to stop
or to create bigger slides
and um the hacking fest model or the
hanging face ecosystem was in the
beginning just the transformers library
or maybe a few of you know that
transformers before it was named
transformers was called pie torch
bird and then pytorch transformers so we
started with third implementation then
we added a few several another
architectures and now we have like over
70 different transformers architecture
and the whole ecosystem grew from just
training a few models to incomplete
end-to-end machine learning platform
with open source and open science as
building blocks and the heart of it is
our hugging phase hub
and the hiking phase hub
consists out of two pillars the modern
hub and the data set hub the model hub
is a central repository for
state-of-the-art models across different
frameworks the hub has already mentioned
hosts over 15 000 public models from the
transformers library but not also for
only from the transformers library also
have now integrations into an other nlp
libraries like anna lnp or maybe for the
german pure player
and we also have integrations from
vision libraries like tim and speech
libraries like speech brain and espnet
so you can find
not only nlp models on huggingface.com
and the newest edition which we are very
proud of is like we added integration
and support for fast ai models and
scikit-learn models
each model consists out of a model card
file repository managed by git so you
have version control by default and a
setting page here you can see like two
examples the left one is a scikit learn
model um card repository for
um doing the wine quality challenge on
kegel and on the right side you can see
um a vision transformers for object
detection using our new object detection
widget which we released yesterday
and basically any or almost any of these
15000 models provide the model card and
the inference which the model cards
mostly host information about
how the model was trained how you can
use it which limitations it has and also
the inference widget where you can like
basically seamless test the model inside
the browser without the need to run any
python code or any yeah start any
virtual machine container to just test a
few models so it's super nice feel free
to go to hackingface.com models
afterwards search for models in your
language in the tasks you want to do and
then just try it out
in addition to like the visual and the
ui we have for the hub the hub also
offers or has its own sdk which can be
used to programmatically interact with
the hub to make integrations into
existing machine learning machine
learning ecosystems or into your own
pipelines the code snippet you can see
here we are basically creating a new
class extending the pi charge
model and the model hub mix in the model
hub mixing is coming from the sdk which
enables basically the class to be saved
and pushed to the model hub and to be
loaded from the model hub so with this
like small little code snippet you can
make any python model compatible with
the hugging phase hub and have an
automatic version control
cloud storage for all of your machine
learning models and you can train on
machine a and load it on machine b
without like having to do any heavy
lifting or migrating something
the second pillar of g-hub is the data
setup which offers now over 1200 public
available data sets for nlp speech
vision
tabular data and many more areas you can
also use the hiking phase hub to
the data setup to host your own data
sets public or if you have like in a
company context privately and you can
basically upload your csv file to it use
the data sets library and load your csv
file from there and have like an object
you can use for training with the
transformers library and you don't need
to write any like loading scripts
everything handled by the datasets
library
the next we are going to take a look at
the open source libraries from the
ecosystem
tokenizer and transformers are the
building blocks right now from modern
nlp with tokenizers you can convert your
normal human readable text into tokens
and then into ids the ids then can be
used with transformers to
train a model or to run inference and as
mentioned earlier we started with one
bird model and now we have 74 different
state-of-the-art transformer
architectures for vision nlp and speech
and we are growing super fast and
hopefully we can like achieve the 100
different architectures as soon as
possible so if you have any ideas or if
you read any like research paper and
think okay this would be a good for fit
for the for new architectures and
transformers feel free to open a github
issue on transformers with like a model
request and if it's interesting we
can integrate it into the transformers
library
also very interesting and helpful for
yeah using transformer sliders the
transformers library is that we are
providing a trainer api to easily
fine-tune a pre-trend model on a given
task and data set
and the nice part about this is
basically this trainer abstract all of
the heavy lifting for writing training
loops evaluation loops and managing the
underlying infrastructure the trainer
supports setups for cpu gpu multi gpu
and also multi-node multi gpu and tpu so
it's like super easy for you to run like
your training or give it a test run on
your local machine on your cpu and then
go to a big gpu cluster and run exactly
the same training script
providing your hyper parameter as
training arguments and at the end of the
evaluation you can push it to the app
and then use it for inference
our newest released open source library
are accelerate and optimum
accelerate is a fully pie touch-based
approach to training it's basically the
opposite of trainer it's not abstracting
anything
accelerates lets you handle your own
training loop but what it is what it's
abstract it's like the heavy lifting or
for the infrastructure so the code
snippet you can see on the left with the
divs um that can be run on cpu gpu
multi-gpu and multi-node multi gpu and
also tpu so you are also writing your
own custom training loop adding a few
accelerate properties like the device
and preparing the model and optimize and
data for it and accelerate will find out
under the hood okay is you running on a
cpu machine is he running on a gpu or on
a tpu so you can basically use the same
training script for the
infrastructure you want to use and then
optimum which has been released last
week is our new open source toolkit for
transformers production performance we
are going to enable maximum efficiency
for training and running model on
specific um hardware in the example you
can see and how you can like quantize a
transformers model with optimum and
intel's low precision optimization tool
for the intel xc and cpus with that you
can like use the pre-trained models find
unit and even like optimize it for your
dedicated hardware to run on
the next yeah part of the ecosystems are
our main managed training solution and
there we have the auto nlp service which
is which is like 100 auto ml library for
nlp but you can also now do speech and
vision tasks since transformers are
able to do it with auto analytic you can
train state-of-the-art transformers
model without any experience or
knowledge you just need to provide a
data set and auto nlt will handle the
rest behind the scenes that select the
best model architecture for your task
and make sure that evaluation is correct
it uploads it to the hub and then can be
used for inference so it's really like
the three lines of code you can see on
the snippets it's creating a project
uploading your data
executing train and then you are ready
to use it for inference and then on the
other side we have stage maker
in a particular sagemaker training which
um also obstructs the heavy lifting for
the infrastructure you need for deep
learning but you can focus on how you
want to train your model so with
sagemaker you are providing the training
script and stage maker will take care of
the managing the underlying
infrastructure so it will start the ec2
instance you want to use for training it
will stop the ec2 instance after
training it will upload your model to s3
it provides logs and cloud watch it has
an integrated profiler to make sure that
you are not running into any bottle legs
you have a debugger where you can
basically hook into your training and
make sure okay you don't have any
performance degradation
and
of course after you have trained your
model using either the open source or
auto nlp or sagemaker you are most
likely to want to test your
model before going into production
that's where spaces can shine in
spaces is a
yeah a simply way to host machine
learning demos directly on hiking phase
co and currently we support two sdks to
let you build cool machine learning apps
with python one of it is dreamlit and
the other one is creato so you can
basically create your space using
streamlet and cradio hugging face will
make sure it holds that it will be
hosted correctly it will be exposed to
the public and then can be used and
spaces is currently in beta but will be
available soon for all of you and if
you're already interesting in spaces you
can go to hackingface.com spaces we have
i think around over 150 different spaces
to test out
nlp use cases
speech use cases and also vision
and the last part of it after you make
sure you have like an optimized trained
model you tested it in your space and
are fine with it you want to yeah put it
into production and that's where our
influence solutions are needed currently
we offer three different kind of
inference solution the first is the
inference api which also powers our hub
and the 15 000 models on the hub so if
your model is available on the hanging
face hub it's also automatically
deployed to the inference api so if you
are uploading a model to the hub which
is compatible with the libraries i
mentioned earlier with transformers the
inference api will pick it up deploy it
and it's ready for you to use so
basically all of
the knowledge and the doing for
deploying a model will be abstracted and
handled by us
with sagemaker on the other side you can
also host these models but inside your
own controlled environment so if your
company has some compliant compliance
guidelines you can easily manage them
with using sage maker for hiring phase
in addition to this stage maker allows
you to extend your inference code so if
you want to have a custom pre-processing
or post-processing you can define this
with using sagemaker
and our yeah most exciting new inference
service which isn't released yet but if
you followed our social media you notice
that we are going to have a live event
next tuesday september 28th where we are
announcing hugging face infinity so if
you haven't signed up you definitely
should and keep an eye on our social
media to learn more about infinity
and infinity will be our own
containerized solution to deploy fully
optimized influence pipelines for
state-of-the-art transformer models into
your own production environment and the
most exciting thing about us we achieve
down to one millisecond inference
latency for board
like models on gpu and four to ten
milliseconds on cpu-like models
okay before we jump into the hands-on
session are there any questions we could
answer
yes i think there
is a question from
les guessing
um do you need to tell auto nlp which
algorithm to use or will pick the best
one because the table of data on aws
does
uh regression and classification and
what are the algorithm choices for and
or beyond hugging things
so in auto nlp you don't need to define
um the algorithm behind it basically
what you are doing i can go back to the
slides is you are
you are telling auto nlp which task you
want to do so in nlp vision of speech
you have like different tasks you want
to find tune on example of a task in nlp
is text classification or question
answering for speech it would be
automatic speech recognition and vision
for example object detection or image
specification so you can create your
auto nlp project with your dedicated
task for example text classification
upload your data set where you need like
a specific format for text
classification would be you need to have
like one column with your text and
another column with your label you want
to like train on and then ultra nlt will
train multiple models behind the scene
pick the best architecture optimize the
hyper parameters and provide you not
only the best model also the other
models if you are curious to look into
what auto nlp has done
oh thanks along those lines so is there
a menu of algorithms or tasks as you
call them to choose from or or it
doesn't automatically select so so i'll
see a menu of tasks that i can pick and
that's all and then i just upload my
data
yeah
yeah like um as of speaking right now we
launched a new landing page i think two
hours ago so if you go to
hackingface.com to nlp you can see our
new ui which has like screenshots of how
you can create a project how it's going
to look like selecting your tasks
providing the data and then running your
model with having like multiple like
runs with the performance and how far
they are
wow that's fantastic and then ultimately
it outputs to uh an https endpoint is
that what it is an inference endpoint
you and
now you've got to build your own front
end right or is that connected to
creatio or something like that
no so basically auto nlp is using the
hub at the hunting fest hub as backend
so all of the ultra nlp trained models
will be uploaded to the height and face
hub and since the hub is again connected
to the inference api all of your models
trained will be available for inference
and you can use the like dedicated https
endpoint wherever you want using like in
rest clients like insomnia or creating
your own web app using react and then
integrating it
fantastic thank you
um i have two other questions here one
from sean soden
i hope i pronounce it right what will
you recommend to start learning her in
face and he prefers books
so i would definitely recommend our new
course it will like start with how well
what is transformers what are encoder
decoder models what are like secrets to
sequence models then the second part
will go into detail how you can
fine-tune your own transformer model
using a pre-trained model like bird
so that's definitely a good starting
point for it each section of the course
has a video to go through and code
example and also additional like
exercises
and those are accessible from the
hugging face website right
yeah it's huge dot co slash course
another question is uh from jerry wing
chang do you ask me to define language
of the data set for
or auto nlp
um
there are multiple options so when
creating an auto nlp project you can
select the task uh sorry the language of
your data set so if you have like a data
set in german you can select german in
english it's english but you also can
train multilingual models so you could
have like a data set containing german
and english
data points
and uh
next one we have from our archery varada
yusuf uh what uh and he's asking why
ottawa he can't use or be used in the
sagemaker
so auto nlp is basically not just the
script which is being executed auto nlp
is like a whole solution and service
which requires just more than running on
a vm we have a like a database for
example to managing all of the
experiments so it's like not that easy
to run on stage maker but um
it is used behind the scenes so auto nlp
also uses stage maker to run
all of your training
so auto nlp is it in the cloud or what
yes
can't we run it
on local machine
for now
i think the question is if it can run on
premise or it can be only done via cloud
uh rest service
yes so
auto nlp is basically a sas service
hosted and managed by us
but if you are interested in like
hosting it inside your own company
environment feel free to reach out to us
and we can hop on a call and like
discuss how we can make this work
any other question if not we can
jump into this session and answer the
questions later
right
i i don't see any questions
okay
then
next part of this is dd
we are showing you how easy it is to use
the sagemaker integration with a hugging
face so you hopefully can see in my
browser where i'm on the huggingface.co
website
and
what we have built with sagemaker and
the amazon team is basically a seamless
integration from the hugging phase hub
to sagemaker and you can when you go to
a model
and for example here you can see all of
the models and select
a bird model
you have like these quick action tubs
basically and bird base is a pre-trend
model so it's not fine-tuned for any
specific task so we can use it to run
training on
any task we
probably want and when you click on
train you can select an amazon sagemaker
you will get a product pop up selecting
your tasks so if i want to find you not
train my word-based model on text
classification i can select my task and
also then i need to select okay where
i'm going to start my training so if i'm
running inside sage maker on a sagemaker
notebook instance or session maker
studio i can select aws config and if i
want to start my training from your
local machine i can select local machine
and then we are creating a code snippet
which you can copy to either your local
machine or to sagemaker which will take
care of um or basically provide spoiler
plate code for your training and the
only thing you need to do is to extend
the hyper parameter on how many epochs
you want to train which data set you
want to use
so but like since training takes more
than just a few minutes we are not
training a model we are more deploying a
model so for deploying a model we want
to select the model which is already
pre-trained therefore we can use the
filters on the left side and say okay we
want to have a model
fine-tune for question answering select
our preferred model in this case we go
with the deep set roberta based squad 2
select and deploy the amazon search
maker
and again select our configuration since
i already started the sagemaker notebook
instance i can go with aws
copy to clipboard
jump into my notebook where i just
basically upgraded the sagemaker sdk
paste it
and then
yeah sagemaker sdk will deploy our model
to
the
sagemaker instance if my kernel would
run
okay it runs perfect so this will like
take a few minutes and until this i can
show you what's happening behind the
scenes so
we are now in the aws management console
at the sagemaker service
okay one second
and when going to stage maker you have
like multiple different areas so since
hmac isn't only your service for
training and inference it provides a lot
of more functionalities as ground rule
for labeling data notebook
which i already mentioned is where you
can run and create hosted and manage
jupiter notebook instances
processing which is
basically the service before training an
inference when you want to like
pre-process thousands of data points and
then multiple more and since we created
our inference service what sagemaker
will do it will create a model
containing the information we provided
so the deep set roberta large squad two
fine tuned model and our task which was
question answering then we are creating
some endpoint configuration which
contains information about okay and
which model we want to deploy which
instance we are going to use in this
case we select the dm56 large instance
which is a cpu instance and how many
instances we want to launch on so if we
want to scale up the model we can easily
adjust the configuration and go with
instead of one initial instance count we
can go to two
also if you want to have like auto
scaling which is sagemaker
or sage maker can do you can go into
define
matrixes on how you want to scale your
model so if the cpu usage is above 70
percent you can say okay now scale up to
another instance and this all the steam
is going to be managed by these endpoint
configurations and out of an endpoint
configuration we have our endpoint which
will be available as
http um api to be used with
the rest client the front end or with
yeah sdks provided by amazon
oh great
well that was fast so as you can see we
have um maybe to go through the code
again we have our configuration for our
model with roberta based for two we have
our task we have the hugging face model
which we have seen in the console and
then we have to deploy method which
deploys the hacking phase model to stage
maker with our configuration for our
instance time and our the number of
instance and this deploy method returns
a predictor which we then can use to to
run inference so if i copy this down and
change the question to
[Music]
the meetup
is run in
first hold
by
pi data
and change the question
who runs the meetup
we can see it returns our like
predicted answer with pi data
and that's how you can deploy basically
any of the transformer compatible models
from the hub to stage maker to use for
inference and if you are done testing
you can use the predictor again
and execute the delete endpoint method
and everything will be cleaned up and
you are not like wasting tons of money
for having end points running without
using them
okay that's it any more questions
yeah i'm curious anytime i deal with aws
and i'm curious about the same thing for
for hugging faces
how do i know how much this is going to
cost me in that suddenly i won't get a
bill and i'll be broke
so for for stage maker it's pretty easy
um search maker when you go search for
google on amazon sagemaker pricing you
have like um dedicated tabs for each of
the different services so for inference
you can see the insta at the price per
hour per instance type so in our case we
have the m5 instance which costs around
i think 50 to 70 cents per hour and then
you can like multiply by the number of
hours you run so a normal month has
around 750 hours with the 50 cents you
should be around something like
yeah
300 200 or something
and that's how you can calculate and
also aws has a new pricing calculator so
you should definitely check this out
which makes calculating all of the
prices for your services way easier
great thank you
are there more questions maybe
okay then again we can switch to the
second talk yeah thanks for
for all of your questions and
as i said if you have any questions
after the meetup or tomorrow or the next
week feel free to contact me wherever
you want or open an issue on our github
repositories or on the forum we are
happy to have you
i have a question
yep
does a hugging face hire
actually
yes and uh do you hire uh only a remote
position or
because i don't know the headquarters
where are they yeah
so yes we hire and you can go to
angel.co and search for a hug space we
have like many different positions open
full-time remote or also on-site and
currently we have offices in paris and
in new york
okay thank you very much
so thanks philip i think we are all
stunned by what hugging face can do so
that's probably the reason why there are
no more questions
and um yeah so
please reach out to to philip or to our
organization team from
hamburg natural language processing and
we will try to find some more answers
for you
okay
thank you very much philip
so i guess now we'll go on
a short break um
let's say about
13 minutes break
so we'll go back at
20 o'clock
8 o'clock in germantown that was great
philip thank you very much
so it's a great pleasure to have leticia
park alabescu with us today
and
she's going to share some really nice
insight about the transformer
architecture
so leticia studied physics and computer
science and she's currently a phd
candidate at heidelberg university
her research is focusing on multi-modal
machine learning that is the integration
of it vision and language
and also she has a youtube channel
called fai coffee break with leticia
and uh you should definitely check it
out because it's very didactic and uh
entertaining as well so definitely check
it out
so without further ado
please the floor is yours let it say you
can start
thanks alex for the kind introduction
and thanks for inviting me to speak to
you here and i'm so happy that philip
advertised how easily you can use
transformers with hugging face because
my whole talk will be about transformers
and it will be about how you can use
transformers on more than just text
so i will explain to you what
multi-modal transformers are and i will
explain a subset of multi-modal
transformers so those transformers that
are looking at images and text only
and then i i mean the first two parts
will be of course about
their success but i will also have a
last part where i will show some own
work about um uncovering the limitations
of these vision and language
transformers
but before i can explain you what
multi-modal transformers are i think i
first have to you know spend two words
on explaining multi-modality i also have
to explain to you
just in two words what the transformer
is and yeah then we can talk about
multi-modal transformers so
multimodality in machine learning is
when we have a system that handles
multiple modalities i know that's not
the most informative definition we have
heard so i will just give an example so
if i have a piece of information like
for example a mountain i can convey you
that piece of information by showing you
for example an image that is depicting
that mountain
i can also have a piece of text that
speaks about you know that mountain i
can also verbally speak about that
mountain so this information will
come to you as for in form of sound
waves and these are examples of
modalities that are you know very
human-like they are very
aligned to our human sensors
but there are also more alien-like
modalities especially if we focus on
machine learning that is not so much
about human computer interaction but is
machine learning that is for example
aiding some other sciences like physics
and biology we can
also look like
data that is for example just
temperature absolute temperature which
we humans cannot
receive we can perceive only relative
temperature it can be something like
pressure or an extension of you know the
electromagnetic spectrum we call visible
light and we have our pictures in a very
tiny
fraction of what is actually going out
there in the universe so we could have
you know a machine learning system
looking at x-ray as gamma rays that
microwave or radio you know and we can
even go crazier for example
gravitational waves
but for this talk i will just focus on
you know the more human-like modalities
um and uh yeah focus on how the
transformers handle those
and why a machine learning system
endowed with you know multimodal powers
is more advantageous than you know a
machine learning model focusing only on
one modality
is for example very nicely described in
this acl 2020 paper by bender and caller
and you can read the paper on your own
it's really
it's a nice paper we have also covered
it on our channel of course
but in a nutshell if um
to just say why
multi-modal system is better than a
unimodal one if we for example want to
achieve natural language understanding
that this paper tells us that
language enough so text alone is for
example not enough to achieve natural
language understanding so um just
to think about it
if we have a machine learning system
that has seen a hammer that has felt a
hammer that has uh that has you know hit
a nail with a hammer that system
understands better what the idea of a
hammer is than for example a system that
has just read about hammers on the
internet and extracted some statistical
correlations that tell it for example
that hammers are appearing in the same
contest context often with nails
and another argument is made by
this paper experience grounds language
by yunatan biscuit collaborator
that
you know makes a road map to what we
really want to
do or what we the authors think we
should do if we want to get to natural
language understanding so if we want to
move away from text only so the first
two steps of this roadmap are where we
are right now so
we have large corpora of text or you
know the text that has been written on
the internet and we have language models
that are really well capturing and
parroting back what um you know they
have read
but to have a mother that really you
know understands things or starts to
understand things we need perception so
that model needs to have more sensory
inputs for example vision and here um
be able to hear and so on um and that is
you know multi modality that is my what
i am very interested in but of course
the the story perhaps starts for me
there but it doesn't end there if we
want to go to nlu natural language
understanding because we also need
something like embodiment so um
while in the third step um
system is passively
you know listening or watching
everything we feed it with in the
embodiment case where the system has a
body it can also trigger its own
training instances by interacting with
the world and then of course the apex is
the social world where the system can
interact socially with other agents or
with us
and uh yeah but i will focus on step
three and uh
i will tell you right now what it has to
do with transformers because when i
started my phd a few years ago the field
looked entirely differently from now so
now we have this transformer
architecture that does everything but
before if we had for example two
modalities like image and text we had
the cnn that was processing the image we
had the lstm that was processing the
textual modality and
the problem was the following
while cnns and lscms are quite good at
processing their own modalities it's
problematic when we want to integrate
what they give us because the cnn in a
sense summarizes the whole image into a
vector and the lstm does the same thing
cramping everything in the single vector
and then we have two vectors which
coming from a different modality and we
want to integrate those things
and um well this is problematic because
never at the beginning so the first
layer of the cnn cannot interact with
the other modality with the first cell
of the lstm or something so uh
until the bitter end
so the system and the end has to work
with just this summary representation
and this is not okay and the problem is
exactly because we need very different
architectures for
very different kinds of data
cnn is you know focused on grid like
structure and lstm is for sequences um
especially i mean 2d convolutions i'm
speaking of so the transformer is the
exact opposite of it the transformer
does not discriminate between modalities
anymore so as long as your modality is
represented as a vector the transformer
can work with it because transformers do
not work with grids do not work with
sequences they work with sets
and sets are unordered
and
whatever structure is between these
vectors like for example a sequence we
have then to
really
weirdly sometimes uh put back into the
transformer so here i have a very
simplified view of a transformer block
as presented in the original attention
so you need paper and here your text
your sequence is represented as vectors
but you see these vectors are you know
um
if you exchange them if you just permute
all these vectors or or the words the
transformer wouldn't notice in this case
that something happened so
the result in the end would be the same
because every computation here is in
parallel and if you really want to you
know
make it obvious that there is a sequence
here that there is some
order in that set of vectors which is
now our text we have to introduce these
strange things these positional
embeddings which are kind of identifiers
that are telling um that are added to
the vector representations that are
telling the system look this is the
first word this is the second word and
so on and because of these positional
embeddings if we so if we exchange the
word vectors themselves the positional
um
embeddings do not rotate too because you
know the first position embedding is
just for the first position so this is
how we you know put back into the
transformer the
the
sequence
sequential nature of text
so the you know the question now with uh
modalities and multiple modalities is
how do you represent that as a vector
and how do you
encode that structure or order if there
is some back into the transformer for
example with text you use these
positional embeddings
and you know the question
of how to represent everything as a
vector is
not that simple as represented here but
in text you could uh just you know
assign a unique vector for each
word in the english vocabulary or
whatever language you're you're working
with
tokenization is a little more
complicated but this is you know a very
simplified view
and uh the question is how then to
represent images of vectors because to
be able to process them with a
transformer and here the answer is
easier than expected because images are
in a sense vectors already in fact there
are matrices um in a grayscale image for
example
and
if you just take each row of that matrix
and write it one after the other you
already have a sequence and you have
represented your image as a sequence
and uh yeah this would could look
strangely like why would you do that but
this is how cathode ray tube monitors
and you know all tvs were actually
drawing the image back in the day now
it's a little different but that's how
it was and um
then the question is but then how does
the transformer know that this is you
know the upper
part of the of the image or the lower
part well positional embeddings this is
the answer and yeah sometimes i mean uh
vectorization of images is a little
different or a little more complicated
because if you do it like i just did
then you really blow up your sequence
length because you can imagine a high
resolution pixel has um image has a lot
of pixels so a lot of rows and this
then could get you into trouble but um i
mean if you if as long as you can
imagine a vector is a way to vectorize a
modality then you're fine and you can
throw it into a transformer so um
the text transformer is something i
think you're familiar with so um the
thing is that
we have our input vectors and the
self-attention layer lets every vector
be informed on every other vector in the
sequence
and then the
feed-forward fit for word neural network
produces an output so the thing is with
transformers is that
as many vectors as you have as input as
many vectors then you have as output in
the in encoder so
um
yeah but the the thing is that these
vectors that are coming out of it are
better informed on if the the whole
context because you know the
self-attention lets every vector
communicate with every other vector and
then on these output vectors you can do
something like
a classification or something and
then the question is okay i mean this is
how it was introduced for text but how
to do it for images well a simple
solution uh which in practice has this
problem of uh big sequence length but
you could just take the image back to
the text vectors and then append the
image vectors to those and assign some
positional embeddings that sometimes are
i mean they should be modality specific
because images are ordered a little
differently than than
text but then you have a you know a
simple
text image transformer and if you
then can imagine a vector format for any
other modality you're thinking about you
can have you know cramp every modality
into a trans uh transformer and let it
do things with it
and uh yeah i mean it's it is sometimes
a little specific on what the modalities
are but you know the basic principle of
thinking about it is this you know how
to vectorize it and then how to throw it
into a transformer and just to give you
some examples of how this and what you
know transformers have done on different
modalities here is for example video
bird where you can process a video with
a transformer and of course the question
is how to cramp a video into vectors
that's you know that's the interesting
part of that paper the rest of the paper
is just a transformer then we have image
image text transformers and they for
example this one has been trained on 12
tasks in at the same time and it can do
12 things at the same time which is you
know crazy but
this is what it can do then uh so the
latest papers that are coming out for
example perceiver i o are very clear
about the fact that look you can use
this transformer for
anything you want especially this
receiver i own is um
handling uh the problem of uh linearly
control of quadratically scaling
attention so they here really advertise
you know just bring your modality we can
handle it with it
and uh
there are also some more you know
alien-like modalities like for example
sequences of amino acids that are also
processed by transformers to create to
predict protein structure or you know
you can take music and produce dance
moves and these are just some examples
what you can do with transformers and i
hope i convinced you with these examples
that you can
use transformers for everything nowadays
and um yeah and then my question is uh
what i'm focusing on during my phd is uh
yeah what about image and text so uh
here i will focus on uh
vision and language models basically on
vision and language transformers and uh
so far i advertised oh well it's a
transformer as long as it's a vector
problem solved well the thing is it's
not that easy because things start to
get modality specific
so
even though vision and language can be
represented the same
because you know there are vectors in
the end
vision and language are not born equal
in a sense so vision is an evolutionary
necessity it evolved independently in
multiple organisms
and the language as far as the our
sophisticated version goes it's the
human stroke of genius and
they're they're quite unequal in their
information content so if we look at
language
and if i
say things i often do not you know say
obvious things like i don't repeat every
day that the sky is blue because that's
common knowledge and everybody knows
that and
uh if i also say something like the cat
is furry uh i can
you know i cannot change many things in
order to preserve the same meaning or
approximately the same meaning so i can
exchange cat with
some synonyms but there are not so many
synonyms that you can think of to place
there instead of cat but on the other
side on the visual side
cats
can look
so differently right and here are just
some example of different cats but
imagine the same cat i mean even the
same cat is problematic because uh the
same cat can be captured by different
cameras with different resolutions
different quality different lighting
conditions
from different angles
and yeah you create a combinatorial
problem there because you know
you have many kinds of the same thing
but
you know vision might look
strange because of that i mean a very
hard and very um so combinatorial uh
blow up but the problem is actually that
the uh the problem is more the language
side because the language side is then
not easier because you have less
combinatorial option to replace words
over there but it's actually even worse
because if i have
if i say this cat is furry
uh you have to infer a lot of
information that is not really there so
on the visual side you see how the cat
looks like you see an angle at least of
the cat but on the the textual side you
really have to know which cat i mean
right so it can be a lot that stands
behind just uh these symbols
so there is uh this problem of
inequality between
these two modalities and this makes
integrating vision and language even
with transformers hard that it's a
surgery director since you said you
prefer also to take questions
one
ask from uh i hope i pronounced it
correctly
namrata
so can a masked model be used in
multi-modal transformer and how does it
ensure the predicted values will lie in
the same feature space modality as input
yeah
and
i have a slide for later for that
so i i'm happy to to just introduce the
answer to your question in the talk and
if i don't address it correctly then
please um just ask again okay yeah
thanks
um yeah but really great question and uh
yeah i think it's almost the next slide
yeah
okay so
uh
multimodal so here is a vision and
language transformer a very you know um
naive one it's the the one where we just
have the vectors that are corresponding
to the text and we just append the
vectors that are corresponding to the
image and we throw everything into a
transformer but now the question is how
do we really do it i mean it's um
in principle nothing stands against
doing it this way but in practice
um
in this architecture that i'm just
presenting here every uh token on the
language side communicates with every
token on the on the image side and of
course every token on an image
communicates with every other tokens on
on every
so on the image side so there's a lot of
communication there and um
the problem is if we don't know
so
this the transformer especially at the
beginning during training and if it has
little data it won't necessarily know
which of all these connections that are
possible right in the for the
self-attention of for computing those
scores is are okay and which are not so
we would like to have something of an
inductive bias uh to limit the search
space of which
you know who is connected to whom
and uh therefore i present to you now uh
vi albert wilbert it's it's a vision and
language architecture how for example
they do it we have the text we
represented as a vector uh no
in mystery there we have a transformer
module and just like bert and it's
getting this as input processing it will
self-attention getting as many vectors
as you have as input as output but the
vectors are you know better ones
informed uh ones
and um
we take the image and if we would take
now every row of the image we would have
many many rows our sequence length would
be increased and that's sometimes
problematic if we have
not a linearly scaling transformer but
one of the those others and the this the
solution the authors of wilbert took is
to just take um the image and transform
it into patches and then you have some
means like for example a pre-trained
faster rcn but not necessarily to
convert every image patch into vectors
and then you have these so-called
co-tension transformer modules which are
you know the usual transformer modules
but the attention layer is of the visual
side is allowed to communicate with the
um
textual side and vice versa so in this
layer there is exchange there's cross
modality happening uh
parts from one are informed
about the other but then because we want
to limit you know the communication a
little bit because uh now there's a you
know the opportunity for each modality
to stay with itself and communicate with
itself uh here and we can you know stack
as many players as we can fit into
our gpu
and um and we have a vision and language
transformers as there are really some
out there and
but now we have to do something with it
i mean we have to train these weights
and here is i think where the mass
language modeling and comes in because
we want to
get so to do some pre-training like you
know bert is also pre-trained on news
and wikipedia data and we want to
achieve some um
universal image text representations or
generic visual vision and language
representations these uh you know are
the advertisement words but the question
is how generic are the presentation
anyway but
uh to to have some a transformer that a
pre-trained one that has some general
idea about you know
vision and language and them together so
we need some pre-training tasks and one
pre-training task is multimodal must
like language modeling which is exactly
like mass language modeling
but better i mean easier in a sense so
what we can do is you know for example
mask out the word mountain over here so
that is a mask and the mother then has
to predict that mask but in in the
language only setting if you say that is
uh that could be anything that is a cat
that is a dog that is anything but now
because we have also the image right so
the the transformers are also looking at
the image the search space is
constrained because of because we see a
mountain in the image so um
that mask token the mountain now has to
be predicted uh mountain and there is no
much you know uh um freedom there
and um
[Music]
uh the the question is how can uh
the model ensure that it's in the that
the predicted values will lie in the
same feature space and modality as the
input well the
the thing is that
at the end so the transformer will have
as many
vectors as it has gotten as input
but while the input vectors are you know
very modality specific so the the
vectors on the left-hand side here are
text vectors and the ones on the
right-hand side are image vectors well
after so many much communication through
the co-tension modules uh the
representations will be a little mixed
and i i mean my personal opinion is that
they're not as mixed as they should be
because the tasks are not enforcing that
correctly and so on but um yeah the
thing is that that's the goal to in the
end have something that is cross-modal
so that you have a mountain
representation that is now both knowing
about you know the language
representation of mountain and the image
one and how everything is in that
context
yeah but uh it's not hard to do mask
language modeling because you know just
the word that is masked is then
predicted
i hope this answers your question
another you know thing that one can do
during pre-training is to
have uh the model predict
what
what
is that region that a patch corresponds
to or something like that and it's there
are many you know pre-training tasks and
uh
but the one that i think is most
important for what i'm going to tell you
later is the image sentence alignment
score so these models get a lot of
images and their captions and if uh it
gets an image in the caption it should
say that the image sentence alignment
score is high because no a caption
represents the image so you know the
content should be quite aligned there
but
sometimes in 50 of the cases then the
model gets an image and a sentence that
is
not its caption it's a caption of a
different image and then the image
sentence alignment score should be low
so this is how the model learns to align
the left hand side and the right hand
side because for example for something
like multimodal mass language modeling
it could also get away with just the
text just like you know birch does mass
language modeling without image
information
right and after all this pre-training on
millions of for example ms coco images
and captions or conceptual captions it
you know should have learned something
about images text and then together
but then
we have to do something with it right
downstream tasks and uh these paper
trains uh fine tunes uh such this
wilbert model
vision and language model on the 12
tasks but i will just for example
highlight here four on this slide and
speak about visual question and
answering where you have an image and
you have a question and the model has to
give the answer and there is also
something like visual uh common sense
reasoning where
the model also has to give the reason
and
vision and language transformers are
state of the art on this and they are
kind of fighting now which kind of
vision and language transformer are
state of the art and which task but
they're generally i mean there's no
cnn or lstm to see on the leaderboard
nowadays anymore and if you want the
overview of multi-modal transformers
then you can look at this paper
because on
the appendix it has a table five where
there is quite a nice um but now it's a
little old so there's not the new models
here but quite a nice overview of what
the models are what have they been
pre-trained on and
so on
and uh yeah the
the best thing about this is that when i
started these um you know models were
fairly new but now with you know the um
the efforts of the authors and the
efforts of the hugging face community
there's a lot of implementations already
in hugging phase where you can use it
really really simply and uh here is just
an ex so i just looked on on their model
list and i extracted here vision and
language
transformer three of them one vision
transformer speech transformers so now
it's easier than
in any time to do research and for
example this piece of research that i'm
talking
about now about the limits of vision and
language models so when i use lxmod for
example i use the hugging phase library
so uh really this shout out is just
i i really um i i'm really a fan of this
and um
yeah this uh
so the question is
well what is also the limits of this
vision and language models that are
state of the art like everywhere and
this piece of work i've conducted with
albert cutt annette frank and jose
calixto and it's about asking
how can how well can these models count
these vision and language models that
i've just presented and the question
might seem a little odd why are we
interested in counting well counting is
a very cross-model task and i will
see we will see why
because
uh if we want to count in an image we
have to first detect the object
instances in that image because if we
don't detect them we cannot count them
we also have to map different objects to
categories because you know we have to
figure out that all these persons that
we want to count are our persons and
that we're actually counting them right
and of course we have to also align
these instances then to the references
in the textual input because someone has
to have asked for them so
to count for them
and um
and for for probing how well these
models can count we make use of this
image sentence alignment score which
tells us how well an
image and the sentence align or
how uh
how they're not aligned so
um here we we set up this foiling task
and data set where we have we take an
image and we take
um a image
a sentence that is actually
corresponding to the image because there
are four roses in the image but we have
also a foiled sentence where the foil
actually differs from the original from
the correct sentence by one word or one
phrase but quite minor but it has
something wrong like for example it says
that there are five roses in the image
which is not true and with the image
sentence alignment score the model
should tell us whether uh so which of
these sentences is actually correct or
not so what one can expect is that
the image sentence alignment
classification threshold is uh so that
um
the model predicts a correct
uh an alignment where there is actually
a correct sentence and it predicts uh
misalignment where there is the foil but
we also at least assume or expect
that the
image sentence alignment is higher so no
threshold there is higher for the
correct sentence than for the foil
sentence and the corresponding image and
we take three models and i won't spend
more details on that and uh we what we
learn is that with you know just after
pre-training uh these models are
actually not able to solve the task but
if we find yoon on the task
then they're really good i mean i 80
that's actually a reason reasonably good
number
uh and we
and the thing is with fine tuning is
that um sometimes it you know during
fine tuning the model because it has the
capacity picks up a lot of
spurious correlations or things that
i mean the question is always whether
does it solve the this data or does it
really understand and solve the task
and therefore we have actually another
more reliable test which is the
interpolation test it's not even
extrapolation so that would be even
harder but we just take the even numbers
and
um fine tune on them
and test on odd numbers and when we do
this the uh you know accuracy is 50
or around 50 that's random chance and
this pairwise accuracy that tells us
just that the
alignment score between the correct um
sentence is higher than for the fault
sentence that's even in the wrong
direction so
it's not it's even worse so
what we so if we train on even numbers
and test on odd numbers
the model doesn't get it so
even though it has seen these uh
odd numerals during pre-training after
we fine-tuned it on on even numbers i
mean it doesn't get it that it's
actually counting when we see very low
results so um yeah the conclusions are
that
you know even though during after
pre-training this image sentence
alignment works well on ms coco and
conceptual captions the counting task
tells well there is a problem in real
really understanding and that these
generic representations are perhaps not
so generic or there is a lot of
catastrophic forgetting
happening but then the question is why
do we even pre-train if we want to
forget it during fight tuning so we
advocate for more effective pre-training
for testing for catastrophic forgetting
and um
we also don't see many of these tests
that are testing really
particular capabilities of the models
and not so much you know where we solved
this data set in bqa and that's it
because it's a little of a bummer to see
that well we want to be on this stage
three for solving perception for going
towards nlu but then we see that the
models do not even get the tasks of uh
i'm referring here to the interpolation
test
so yeah
that was my conclusion here and i would
be happy to discuss with you if you
perhaps have seen a similar behavior
with other modalities or perhaps if you
have seen successes with it and um
i would thank you i would like to thank
you for your attention and i'm looking
forward to seeing your questions
thank you very much ladies that was
great
it's good to have like a sober view uh
on on this really hyped up architecture
and see what what the currently at least
the limit is
so great
uh any questions
okay so we have one from some student uh
my question is unrelated but which tool
that did you use to prepare this slide
today
you know you won't believe it but it's
powerpoint i learned that tools used
right can actually achieve a lot of good
results yeah i'm using powerpoint even
for my videos if you know them i know
it's uh you know it sounds
uh
a little little but it's actually
working really great powerpoint
okay
other questions
uh if i i have one which is a bit
general you touched on that but it's not
easy to
um
grasp it in detail i guess but what do
you think
goes wrong sir to speak in this uh
more hard tests like why why is it so
much off because it's really like chance
it's not that it's doing okay
it's like yeah you're not not getting
anything so
have you because this is also kind of
going in the direction of explainable ai
so have you unpacked a bit
what types of uh representations are
formed and what really goes on and what
needs to be added potentially
yeah so
i have perhaps a very pessimistic view
on this but um it's really what i said
in the
last sentences that it's a bummer that
the model doesn't understand like
anything so it doesn't even get the task
and um so all these representations that
are formed are very
good for you know
so if if it has been trained on data
that enforces the model to
align for example objects with
dimensions of objects in on the textual
side it will do that so you will see for
example the attention maps focusing very
much on objects so the attention going
from you know the object mentioned to
the
to the object in the image that that
will happen
but um you know it's like um
i i call these models uh
huge statistical correlation detector
machines very complicated ones and they
work very very very well so i i won't
want i don't want to diminish the what
they can achieve but the thing is we can
build with them very much we can build
products but i don't think we can build
linguistic insight or
much insight with them um and uh
i i have but it's not you know um
i don't think that these two anecdotes
are a publishable thing but i've seen
these kind of transformers or models
just not getting the task so just to
explain to you perhaps you know the
natural language interest inference task
where you have two sentences so this is
language only and you have two sentences
like for example it's raining outside
and then
um i know they're outside it's wet right
and these two sentences are in an
entailment relationship because i'm you
know they kind of um
so yeah and um
the model so there are models
transformer models that are trained on
nli so to predict contradiction
neutrality or entailment between two
sentences but
and they work really well they're
state-of-the-art i know 80 90 on
benchmarks but then
you ask such a model and i i know it
with albert so the albert based um nli
model but you ask it
um
what is the relationship between a
sentence in the same sentence so you
have it's raining outside and it's
raining outside what would any human say
it's entailment right
well do you know what the model says
it's contradiction
because it doesn't get it so it's it's
like it's totally outside of its
distribution of its what is has seen
during training so during training it
has seen a lot of
that sentence and that sentence a little
differently it has seen a lot of
unrelated sentences for the
contradiction class but it has never
seen the same sentence in the same
sentence again and it doesn't actually
understand entailment and it's the same
thing but on a bigger level with with
what's happening here so
um in a sense uh
there
these models are detecting the
correlations and the
everything that is uh you know
fulfilling their loss and making their
loss at the end of the day low but
they're not getting it
and
what we can do of course and you know
more data helps
every time and this is what we see
because with more data you get more of
these examples you get more coverage and
um there's a lot of talk about out of
distribution um
and generalization and so on but what i
actually see is just that you increase
the training data so much that
everything you test it on it's not
actually that out of distribution it's
more or less very much in distribution
but so if your whole world is seen
during training then of course you won't
be surprised during testing right
and um yeah because i i so with the
current paradigm i don't really believe
in out of distribution of course there
are some tricks like we you can shift
the distribution and then it just
happens to to work and so on but it's
not like
working uh and it's not really
understanding anything
no
all right
so that ties back um to what is
prominent also kind of discussion in
this artificial uh reasoning corpus from
this only challenge where you have like
simple tasks like counting that
supposedly is and there is a good body
of knowledge from a behavioral point of
view like accounting is any innate
cognitive capacity that humans have
but all the state-of-the-art models fail
spectacularly so it goes it confirms
this unfortunate event even like uh
state-of-the-art transformers okay
oh good to know
so
it is what it is
maybe i can add something to that
because uh in the last nlp made up we
had uh jacqueline didn't hollander
talking about how the brain works in
comparison to
uh yeah modern transformer based models
or
she she explicitly compared it to bird
work and that there are differences and
and she was exactly pointing at those
kind of differences that i mean uh
transformer models are basically
statistical models so as you say they
learn like
covariances and correlations and things
like that but that's not how a brain
does
really understanding a concept and
there's still a lot to do
that we can really model that kind of
work that our fabulous brain does right
so
probably
we need to get away
from only statistical models i don't
know how that's possible but probably
there will be a way in the very
short-hand future i mean there's a lot
going on right i mean attention is is
already losing traction in some parts of
of science right
yeah in some parts but in other parts
it's only starting i think
that's uh so i think we will still ride
this wave for for some time because as i
said we can build beautiful products
with this but the problem is we cannot
build any insight so far and um i also
think that
so where if i would have like a pot of a
lot of money i would invest it in brain
research because our brain is somehow
initialized with a lot of things and you
know i
if you ask me whether if we would take
these transformers and just scale it up
with
tons of more data than we have right now
so like imagine infinite amount of data
and imagine an infinitely big
transformers
if you tell me that if with these sizes
you can really achieve understanding and
um
so or at least
a mother that is indiscernible
from a human
i mean it might be possible i don't know
i wouldn't tell no i wouldn't take it
tell yes because we don't even know how
this thing works so uh therefore i would
really love to um to get a lot like a
breakthrough in neuroscience and um
if we could
you know bet more on on the
initialization we get when we are born
with it um yeah that but of course this
is almost science fiction but
um we have another question
yeah please
i was about to
[Music]
okay so it's a remarkably uh other
specific metrics to quantify how such a
model gets it instead of managing to
fulfill its task
well
uh metrics that's that's a very
it's a good point because i mean what
we're looking at is accuracy on a task
and when i say task i actually mean data
set because we are almost never i mean
when are we ever
testing tasks we are testing data sets
and um
uh
you know there
apart from accuracy there are also some
ways to look into
how the representations change with the
layer how they are also interesting and
i think
these are almost the most insightful
analysis now in mood modality is
ablation studies like for example
so you know the model claims it looks or
you know the authors of the model claims
it look that um that the model looks at
both images and text and it gets
you know gets the answer from from both
modalities because you know you need to
look at the image to answer a question
about image
and
what interesting ablation studies do is
that they for example replace the image
with zeros or you know
corrupt the image a lot so that you the
model cannot rely on the image anymore
or replace it with a random image
and what we see is that instead of
hurting the model by much by you know
taking half of its input yeah right
it's it's okay
because
vqa a visual question and answering has
a lot of biases in just the language
modality so um for example a regularity
is that almost every or too many
too many of the questions which are how
many
cats or something are in the image have
the answer two or three but not ten and
not one and uh not zero uh often so uh
just by you know saying two or one all
the time you uh two over two or three
all the time you get already fifty
percent of the things right so and you
don't even need to look at the image
because how to how many it or it's
already you know uh an answer
between two and three
and um yeah so what how we see that
people quantify this is by these
ablation studies where they remove
something that should be crucial for the
model to really get the answer because
otherwise a human couldn't get the
answer
and what we see is that the model gets
the answer anyway because of these
statistical biases and which are just in
one modality so it gets to answers which
should have never
known uh but
because of the biases and these
regularities
thanks for the questions
we have any more questions maybe
uh yeah i this is ankurish i would like
to ask um
uh thanks for the talk generally uh
i wanted to ask like you mentioned
catastrophic forgetting could be one of
the reasons for the failure of this
model i wonder if you can freeze the
you know pre-trained layers and then
have a deeper layer
have deeper layers during the fine
tuning can that exclude the reason uh
like can that exclude uh care stopping
for uh catastrophic forgetting to be the
reason
it can to some extent but uh also not to
like i mean
and we did that and uh it's um
and the results were still bad so um the
thing is catastrophic forgetting is
there but it's not
the only
issue
yeah uh and um
so the thing i i we also have some
unpublished work i am not allowed to
talk about but yet
perhaps you will see your next video
about it
but yeah so catastrophic forgetting is
not explaining everything of it because
we have these experiments where we
freeze all the weights apart from this
last head that makes then the
classification
decision
yeah
but also
it is a problem
two okay
but you can come you can't even even by
freezing you can't completely exclude it
for some reason
no you can't
completely exclude it because i mean we
we look at this image sentence alignment
head and that on itself can have
some so
that head that um so if you train the uh
take the pre-trained weights and you
take that
head after pre-training
it will have some things that you will
lose if you just retrain that decision
ahead so even if it's a little linear
classifier it could
do some things but
but that effect is in minor yeah
okay thank you
more questions maybe
okay then
let's thank again leticia for this great
stimulating talk
and now there is some time for just
hanging out and networking